so last week Dwayne Johnson went on to
India and he posted a eight minute long
IG TV video talking about the George
Floyd situation as well as like
basically asking where's the president
during this time when we need somebody
to unify us as a country it was very
positively received by the internet and
UK bookmakers actually did a survey and
they found that he is the third most
popular option for president behind
Donald Trump and Joe Biden it's just a
popular opinion but yeah it's the rock
what Rock doesn't know about politics
you know not that Trump does well goes
more about the lie I do wish Trump would
be a little more unifying heated about
the hopeless like he's just divisive his
how it's like dude but didn't didn't we
can't have celebrity as your he said
he's thinking about it not for 2020 but
he says that it's not we're learning
about just lounging 19 George wasn't
Schwarzenegger two-term governor I think
her as a one-term and he was to term got
to tournament thank teacher so Ronald
Reagan was a movie star but none of them
took well Arnold was but the rock I
think the only reason why Arnold didn't
run for president is cuz he is
natural-born yeah that's right otherwise
he would have he always had aspirations
to be young
that guy is phenomenal would you vote
for the yeah I don't know his what I
believe the rocks I have two can you
believe we're time let this is this
that's where we're at yeah I tell you
what I vote for the rock over by day no
so what I he might be a better he might
be at least a very you know why I get it
very smart guy probably learn on a job I
was Oprah running maybe I was I feel
like Oprah Elon Musk if you please like
these people are practical are very
practical at getting a job for Mark
Cuban I would in a heartbeat
yeah probably you know he was a real
snitch during Corona I don't know what
his politics are I don't know another
problem but I like that he's an economic
stud I like that he's made two
businesses work and done very well
managing a sports team and was he the
PayPal guy
he was amazed fortune and tech but he
this is a man [ __ ] yeah
so anybody who's that good at a dictum
it to make you a good president a
manager a good manager your innovative
if you think outside the box
I don't like I start snitching on
everybody though um he was the biggest
[ __ ] turned really yeah yeah Johnny
Biddle just got looking at all the Botox
on his face that's annoying
d oh yeah he's a vain guy because he
kind of was in the limelight probably
didn't get a lot of girls growing up
there's all that stuff think you vote
for Dana White no we're not I think Dana
formula dollar business to business I
just went to your point yeah Dana
Dana's would probably be a little bit
too much like Trump like as the best
friends yeah he would Dan is the guy who
goes like I there's things that I like
about him with that New York Times guy I
was giving him a hard time because I
don't give a [ __ ] what that guy thinks
then that's great but Dana is proudly
proudly it says if he just never reads
not even long text yeah
that worries me it's not that Dana's not
smart and not the Dana isn't an
effective do we know how many rocks read
very well down we don't so I I'm just I
I think amply roughly legit discussion I
don't think that Dana Rock Dana why it's
more Cuban there's a lot I like about
Dana I just do smart people run for
politics well because they can because
what happens is the journalists try to
uncover all your dirt all the skeletons
in closet all all the stuff you were
doing when you shouldn't have been doing
it but it's also an exhausting job and
the smartest minds don't run for me yeah
yeah that's true you've got to be usual
stuff you got to be really into power
you know this right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]